[Music]
people love getting C's Shawn Mendes
performed twice at the MTV VMAs on
Monday night he did his number one duet
senorita with kamila Kibeho and then he
did his other single that's also in the
Billboard top ten if I can't have you
okay si senorita Oh Cinelli's yeah and
it looked like Halsey was a little Ford
during that one
so people noticed on the audience can
that Halsey was on her phone during his
performance and texting so there she is
texting the way not paying attention to
shine so people called her out on social
media yeah so Halsey responded tweeting
can everyone stop saying I was checking
my phone during Sean's performance I was
texting my mom to make sure she was okay
in the audience and also I was dancing
now so here's Halsey a little bit later
in Sean's performance putting her phone
down and starting to dance to the song
but I got I don't think confused by her
statements like because everyone stopped
saying I was on my phone texting but you
were on your phone that you were
actually yeah now you're checking on
your mom but I don't know maybe there is
like some real issue with your mother
you really have check in that second
Blake also every single person who is
giving her crap for checking her phone
live their life on a fall I know and
would take it out to film Shawn Mendes
well he is directly in front of you yeah
it's this right like we talked about
this yesterday with how Camila Cabello
wasn't there for no Monty's performance
if we're wondering if that was a very
pointed decision that she would be
caught on camera either supporting or
not so that's happened that's happened
many times let's think we talked about
the fact like Miranda Lambert and Blake
Shelton specifically for years you don't
be in the same room when the others
performing or accepting the award yeah
but I think yeah well I think like
celebrities just have to learn that when
you're sitting that audience and the
show is on you are on camera just expect
to be on camera like you should only be
on your phone during commercial breaks
that's the only chance to text people
like she should have waited a few
minutes you should be allowed I don't
but I think like people are gonna take
these moments but who can five seconds
if you're not paying attention like
remember there's the JLo Jill was on her
phone during Mariah Carey's performance
for like a half a second people got that
photo
JLo's sitting there on the phone on riot
Cara's performing so I think this is
probably just a lesson for halls he's
like do not touch your phone with
someone else's office always be smiling
always look happy so nuts wait for
commercial breaks not actually we're so
quick to just jump on anyone for doing
anything you know why because you're so
much better than they are that keeps us
just bring up the other JLo which is on
her phone driver Mariah Carey's
performance all of those people aren't
you okay ready